Good morning. I'm Glenn Lowry, director of
the Museum of Modern Art
and I'm delighted to welcome you to this
conversation about Bruce Connor:
It's All True. It really is. This
exhibition was made possible by Hyundai
Card and we are deeply grateful to
Hyundai Card for their ongoing support
for so many projects and exhibitions
here and we welcome their
representatives from Korea who have
joined us this morning.
Funding for this project was also
provided by Jill and Peter Kraus
through their Endowed Fund for
Contemporary Exhibitions,
The Walton Family Foundation, and the Museum of Modern Art's annual exhibition fund.
I'm particularly happy that our
colleagues from SF MoMA are here with us
Rudolph Frieling, curator of media arts
and co-curator of this project
Gary Garrels who comes here as a beloved
former chief curator of drawings and a
curator on this project as well, and
Rachel Federman, who was on the staff of
SF MoMA working on this project when
it began,  and of course here at the
Museum of Modern Art
Laura Hoptman and Stuart Comer. They
were the team that put this
absolutely riveting exhibition together.
I also want to say how thrilled we are
that Jean Conner is with us
I know she started her day yesterday at
a brutally early hour in the morning in
order to be here so gee
thank you so much for making the effort
and for being here and I hope you are as
pleased with this exhibition as we are.
This project really is a collaboration
with SF MoMA and it
it was really SF MoMA's driving impulse
that put this exhibition into play and
I'm thrilled that Neal Benezra, director of
SF MoMA, is with us and Neil wonder if
you would say a few words and as he
comes to the podium let me just take
this opportunity to say congratulations
in a very public way to the absolutely
brilliant job you and your colleagues
did
in building the new SF MoMA.
Thank you, Glenn very very much. You know, SF MoMA and the Museum of Modern Art have
collaborated on many occasions through
the course of our respective 10 years
and Bruce Conner: It's All True is only
the most recent of these and I did a
little research online I found this
release stellar list of exhibitions that
we worked on and in one configuration or
another together:
Gerhard Richter, Andreas Gursky, Oliafur Eliasson, Jeff Wall, Lee Friedlander
Martin Puryear
William Kentridge and Cindy Sherman, just
in the last 10 or 12 years or so
so that's pretty extraordinary.
Glenn, I really do want to thank you as
well for your partnership and friendship.
Glenn has been a wonderful
not just colleague but friend and
counselor to me as we've gone through
our expansion so I'm totally grateful to
you for that.
Bruce Conner was thought for
many many years to be the
central figure in the kind of
counterculture of the San Francisco
Bay area that was the extent of
his reputation to a very good with
considerable extent and now I think it's
safe to say that he's increasingly been
recognized as one of the most
influential artists of our time. To have
this retrospective, which is the first
since his death, presented here in New York
and premiering here in New York
I must say and at the Museum of Modern
Art only testifies to the expanding
reputation and awareness that is bound
to follow
this exhibition and when it comes of
course to San Francisco.
Glenn mentioned Jean Conner, who is
herself a very fine artist in her own right
Thank you Jean for your cooperation and
that of Robert Conway and Michelle Silva
and the Conner Family Trust. You've been
indispensable partners in this project
could not have been accomplished without
you.
Glenn mentioned the curators Rudolph,
Gary, Stuart Comer, Laura Hoptman
here in New York and also
Rachel Federman who was a former
assistant curator of painting and
sculpture at our Museum and was a
central figure in the development of the
project. Before I pass the word back to
Glenn I just want to also acknowledge the
support that we received from the Henry
Luce foundation, which is very, very
important in the organization
of the project and so we're very
grateful to Luce.
So, Glenn, with pride, I'll pass the word back to you
Thank you, Neal for those very generous
words.
So this is a large, sprawling, complicated
rich exhibition and since Bruce Conner
as Neal suggested is not necessarily a
household name
at least here on the East Coast: who is
Bruce Conner?
I only met him once. I shook his
hand in 2000. I wish i knew him
as a person, but as an artist, I think
he's the best known least known artist
in American post-war art and that he is
an artist who inhabited many different
areas of the visual arts discourse
primarily film, cinema but also
primarily and especially at the
beginning of his career
the burgeoning genre of assemblage. And
during our research something
that was very interesting that I came
upon was that when Conner first showed
in New York, he showed as a very young
man, he was 23 years old when his first
exhibition here and up until around
1965, when he stopped
making his assemblages he was a key
member of a movement of assemblers who
included
Robert Rauschenberg and Jasper Johns and in fact over and over
he was mentioned in that in that
particular cohort and when he chose to
remove himself and began to work on
something else he did this at it
deliberately and he chose to leave that
at that millier.
It's All True comes actually from Bruce
himself and I think it's kind of like
this fabulous little window into his
thinking you want to talk a little bit
about the letter and how it sets up this
exhibition, Stuart.
I think it's clear if you've seen the
exhibition the degree to which Bruce was
a shape shifter
and he never settled into one mode of
making for any period of time and when
this letter was written he effectively
compiled a long list of very
contradictory adjectives that had been
used to describe his work in the press
and then Riley said "it's all true" and he
really was elusive
I think the work itself can be very
fugitive he championed the fact that his
work would change over time and he was
true to his interest in cutting and
pasting and reassembling things
constantly changing nature of his own
identity as well as the work itself so
this fact that it was so difficult to
pin him down and now this is the first
major Postumus retrospective it really
is an important chance for us all to
start to pick through these secrets that
have circulated for a long time about
the work. But hopefully without fixing
him too much i think it would be a
disservice if we tried to over define
the work so i hope this exhibition
create signposts for understanding how
important this career was, hugely
important, but without fixing it too much.
It's just to add a servant and also to
create connections which is a a
challenge with such a various body work.
One of the works certainly in our
collection that I'm so pleased is in
this exhibition is "Child" an early assemble piece in it and the result of a
rather monumental conservation research
project.
Laura or Stuart, you want to talk about
what was involved in a sense bringing
that work back to life?
I'll just do a general contextual
comment about conservation in general
and maybe lower can dive into the
details about our brilliant colleagues
in our conservation department who did
restore "Child" after a long and
and troubled history. I think Bruce's
work in general is marked by a high degree
of fragility from the assemblages to
Celluloid itself which as we all know is in
a precarious state right now, film in
general as we know is shifting radically.
So in taking on this exhibition, it was
critical to start looking at both the
objects the films and other materials in
which he worked and really assess how to
preserve them for posterity and to
really take some risks in a way to do
things maybe that had not been done
before and so I wanted to shout out
Roger Griffith and Megan in our
conservation team and Michelle Silver
the Conner Family Trust who have done
heroic work to make some of this work
look its the very very best for this
exhibition. And MoMA
has a long and illustrious history with
Bruce Conner beginning in the
mid-1950s when are one of our
curators Dorothy Miller went to visit
him in Wichita Kansas and returned to
write to start a file on him and write a
note that said talented artist to watch
something of that sort
and when "Child" was created in finished
in 1960 the museum of modern
art made an attempt to acquire this
strange and wonderful work. It's a made
of wax and it is of an homage to Carol
Chessmen, a thief and a rapist, but not a
murderer who was executed by the state
of California too much
to the dismay of many of the anti capital punishment people
Bruce is one of them. "Child"
wasn't acquired in 1960 but
eventually it came to us as a gift
a decade later and by that time it has
deteriorated greatly and over the years
it deteriorated to a point where it was
completely unshowable. Connor came to
visit "Child" several times and we were in
correspondence for more than a decade
about how to work on this and our
colleagues took this on last year as a
as a project that I guess was it was
also an inquiry because we weren't sure
they weren't sure whether this was going
to be possible since that have been had
been failure after failure over so many
years
and you can see it today in this
exhibition it is 99.9
percent of the original material there's
just, I'm looking at my colleagues here
there's just a interior armature and
then one small piece of stocking across
the mouth that is that is a new and
it really is a testament to our
conservators but also to the history of
the staying power of our commitment
to boost Conner that started to 50 years
ago. Neal mentioned counter culture and
certainly that's a theme that runs
pretty much through Bruce's work. Stewart,
you want to talk about the films in
particular and how they intersect with
both countercultural movement and
perhaps even with cinematic history
today?
Sure, I mean I think even if you take two of
the earliest films in the show: a movie
which opens the exhibition and "Looking
for Mushrooms" which marks a period in
which Bruce and Jean Conner move to Mexico and were actively exploring psychedelic
mushrooms with Timothy Leary and really
engaging in this an expanded idea of the
trip
you know all the trips of all kinds and
really exploring a countercultural view
of the world.
I think it's interesting too since this
is the first retrospective in New York
and the extent to which certain West
Coast movements i think were never
fully accommodated in some of the
narratives being written in this city
and it's becoming more and more clear
that on the counter culture itself
produced you know fundamentally
important projects and I think cinema
and experimental cinema in particular
was a major part of that.
So by the time you move from all of
these scenes of death and destruction
that
sort of cut up and we ordered in a movie
and Bruce's reflection on very
American symptoms of a very kind of dark
period during the Atomic Age and then the
escape from that in Mexico and and his
sort of delight in finding an intense
spirituality in every corner of the
streetscape in Mexico City how that then
relates to the final film and he
completed Easter morning in 2006 which
is the final work in the exhibition as
well which is really a counterpoint to
the darkness, sort of apocalyptic vision,
that marks so much of the early work and
in particular early films. And again,
I think he was constantly re-editing and
reworking his own films. There are many
films that were not completed:
he made over 20 films and I
think we've tried to select the seven
films in the exhibition that really
highlight key strategies or key moments
in the work but also films that really
relate to his other practices. Whether it
be in drawing, assemblage making,
printmaking...they were each distinct
bodies work in some ways but there's a
an intense fluidity that I think really
does indicate a strong vision and a
strong reaction to many cultural and
counter cultural developments of the
time.
Yeah, I was always struck by the drawings
and I mean there they have if the film's
have a certain kind of fluidity and
shape-shifting dimension to them
the drawing to have this incredibly
intense almost obsessive dimension to
them. You wanna talk a little bit
about his drawings as a whole?
Conner worked in drawing from the
beginning of his career to the end of
his career in various ways that you
worked with ink he worked with the new
technology of magic marker which is
something that somebody's going to do a
show on sunday because this Yayoi Kusama and many other artists of the time were
working with this and it
changed their drawing.
Conner worked with assemblage, sorry with collage we can be specific paper collage
from the beginning of his career to the
very end and he also pioneered this
technique of manipulating inkblots to
a fantastic effect starting in the 1970s
and again and continuing until the end of
his career and I think that what this is
a body these bodies of work are on their
own islands on their own but they also
relate to his filmic work as well as
assistance as assemblages because of the
concentration it takes not just to make
them but to look at them as well. I think
for Bruce Conner
there is always the acknowledgement of
the viewer in everything that he has
done and especially in the drawings you
can not only admire the steadiness of
hand and this is almost superhuman
concentration or attention to detail
but it also is on us to look at to be
able to look so carefully as closely as
possible in order to divine really the meaning and also the intensity
of the work.
It's a similar thing with the
assemblages you need to put your despite
the pieces of plastic on many of them i
encourage you to put your nose up very
close to them and look at all the
details and this is part also of a kind
of the incantatory, meta-physical, and
spiritual nature of a lot
the work and it has to do with the way
that the works of paper are made
not just what they are but how they're
made
on his part and also how we receive and
how we look at them. I want to come back to
the contradictoryness of It's
All True
I think I can't think of another artist
who so embraced the idea of these
polarities. You read down that list it's
just about every possible condition and
its opposite and he leaves us in a kind
of a quandary.
Right? About what to believe where on the
spectrum of any one of his
contradictions
he fits in it and it seems to me that that
embrace of contradictoryness is one of
the most important themes that runs both
through his practice through the
exhibition and what this work means for
us today. I think one thing you
I think no one could deny is that you
know this work has unbelievable energy
and I mean going back to the idea of the
counterculture different counter cultures had
different energies and so I think it's
very telling to see the punk material
next to the ink-blot drawings for
instance you know one is marked by an
extreme degree of aggression and
violence the other is very spiritual
very ethereal and you know he threw
himself into both of those situations
with a great vigor and so I think just
the way that you know he just
approached everything he did with such
passion, such perfectionism, an incredible
work ethic. I think each of
these things sort of stands on their own
term and they do contradict each
other and I think the other thing that I
mean Bruce for, I met him
twice and so the second time I met him
he was we were discussing film and video
and he was adamant that he would never
ever ever show his work on video and
that of course changed fundamentally and
you see that in
the wonderful installation "Three Screen
Ray" and his first film a movie which
again opens the show originally
conceived this as an installation in the
1950s which is hard to
imagine but it would have been rear
screen projected with other objects and
elements in the room
so finally in the mid early-2000s you know he finally achieves
this idea and even actually before he
experimented with three screen
projection but if you think about the minute detail in the drawings or the sort
of macro and micro spatial
configurations that go on in the
assemblages
and then you're suddenly immersed in
this cinematic immersive space and you
know i think even spatially he
contradicted himself and and you know he
would go very deep into tiny many
details but then he would also he really
understood space.
I think and that's in speaking
"Dimensional Silver" it became very clear
that there was a kind of golden mean
that he had for sketching out the ideal
proportions for a video or film
installation.
So I think he was very aware of how
people encountered his work and so even
if it was contradictory
I just think there was an unbelievable
degree of focus and dedication in the
work that maybe unites all the different
things that might
depart from one another but also the role
play
I think there's one section of the
exhibition where you'll see his campaign
for supervisor for instance or many
strategies he used to get away from
being you know "Bruce Conner" and/or would
really play with different pseudonyms
he did not he would did not want to be
easily absorbed into the art market or
into any official histories he really
was a contrarian and came up with a lot
of different strategies to put that into
play.
Let me turn this over to all of you to
ask any questions that you might have
but if you do have any...
Yes Lee, thank goodness! Kicking off of what you just said about not being readily absorbed and
and the fact that he's a shape-shifter...
was he influential or did that kind of
elusiveness almost preclude that...
was he influential on other artists and
movements?
I mean one artist I can think of who
contributed I mean several artists
contributed to the catalog
Dara Birnbaum in particular I mean just as
one example who
you know i mean when i mentioned
Bruce to her she just got so excited that he
was so influential on me and just
you can see it in her work
i mean just this notion of appropriating
media imagery and what that meant to her.
Certainly he had a major influence but
you're also seeing now i think is a
generation of younger artists
there's an exhibition now at the Whitney
called Mirror Cells which is I imagine
is largerly artists' work in their 20s and
30s and I wouldn't claim at all that
they necessarily knew Bruce's work but
there's no question that there's a
strong resonance between them and I
think a lot of people are looking at the
way younger artists in particular are
not necessarily adopting digital
strategies but are returning to the
object or this idea of this handmade,
ready-made, assembalge object. There's also a very strong gothic sensibility that you
see chiming with the black wax works if
you look at a young artists like Stuart
So I think there's a very strong
relationship between many generations of
artists and Bruce's work. I also wanted
to add about his use of
assemblage which it came early and on
time and during the period of time where
it was raining in the discourses in
New York particularly he was
an innovator in that in an assemblage
and of course a slightly later the
advent of assemblage and Southern and
Northern California he was at the very
center of that moment, beginning from
his first encounters with his fellow
Northern Californian assemblers in 1958
all the way until the mid 1960s when he
stopped making assemblage so he's a Titan
on both coasts in terms of the history
of art in that way and definitely in
terms of contemporary art this way
of working digitally and by and at the
same time for working filmically and by
hand at the same time is something
that's a regular part of the discussion
and in contemporary art in 21st century
art right now. I think something that I
really hope this exhibition will
generate here in New York in particular
is a rather fundamental assessment of how we think about California
because this museum is that very few major retrospective of California artists and
I think the last one would've been Mike
Kelly at MoMA PS1 and for me there are really
important connections between Mike Kelly's work and Bruce's work
they were both polymaths the way they
engaged again with counter cultural
activities and and shape-shifting.
I think there's a strong connection
between the two of them as well but I
think we have to find other approaches
other narratives other frameworks to
position Bruce's work in both within the
California context and
rethinking a more international context
for the work. I agree, because he can't
so easily just be inserted into the
story that were already telling he has
his own stories almost his own planet
his own group of constellations or
however you want to put it but am I
think that makes him
exceptional in so many different ways
and whatever use one sees as new material
it has to be at first and foremost dealt
with on its own terms and then
assimilated into what we already know as
it were. Thank you Lee,
other questions?
It seemed following up on your idea
of California and art that Bruce was not
so much part of the art market and
because your market was far away in
California although
there was certainly in the 60s
business not like the business model
that existed in New York where you are
turning out paintings and sculptures and
paintings and sculptures and you know
pop artists who made brightly colored
things and that was not Bruce and I
think that allowed him to explore so
many different things without being
beholden to that market and is this or
the contrariness of his personality
and his career certainly
influenced the types of works he made in
which has made it very difficult for
let's say the casual art viewer to
absorb all of the variety of media that
he worked in plus the interiority of the
work it is so so intense that you
don't get everything as you walk by
you can't view his show from the window
you have to actually look at it and so
it has made it
I think difficult for art history in
general to embrace until now. Can you
introduce yourself this is Michael Cohen
who has worked with Bruce Conner as his
representative in Los Angeles since 1989
so you certainly know from which you
speak.
You know I think you know the the aspect
that you are touching on for me is the
obverse or the reverse to the
contradictory - which is the resistance
right this is like Bruce as an artist who
really understands the power of
resistance and that resistance is both a
very palpable physical resistance that
you feel as you're working your way
through the exhibition as well as it a
larger kind of metaphysical resistance
to the market to being understood and
accepted in a single way and I think
that those two qualities are very much
of today.
You know there's always an interesting
question about reception when is the
right moment to really reconsider or
even consider an artist and I just think
Bruce's work today feels extremely fresh
and of the moment
precisely because he understood that
the power of resistance in the need for
resistance at a time when you know
culture can seem all consuming. It's
interesting
only Michael in particular first
presented three screen ray at Art Basel
and I think it was that presentation
that led a lot of people in the art
world to really wake up to the
importance of the work and that dovetail
with a moment where experimental film in
particular was beginning to enter the
marketplace for the first time so if you
look at that side of Bruce's work in
particular there's really a lot to learn
and think about and you know even with a
movie very early on he was obsessed with
this idea of collectors in particular
you know treating his films almost like
chinese scrolls that they would pull out
and watch over and over and over again
and again this very personal connection
that you mentioned but you know he was
thinking about modes of viewership that
I think we're not at all central to the
way the conventional logically art world
worked and so it's part of the challenge
now of to what extent do we accommodate
him in those logics until what extent do
we keep him
free of it. Other questions or comments?
If not what I'd like to do is again
thank our colleagues from San Francisco
for having co-curated this exhibition, to
Neal for having provided the leadership
that has guided San Francisco to such a
wonderful place today, to our friends
from Hyundai Card for being with us, to
the Bruce Conner Trust, and to Jean in
particular for sharing this moment with
us and we'll be around if you want to
ask questions or go back upstairs and
look at the exhibition.
Thank you, Laura and Stuart.